85 élèves ont été exclus définitivement
de leur établissement après l'hommage à
Dominique Bernard près de 6 semaines
après la mort de l'enseignant tué dans
un attentat dans son lycée d'arrace le
13 octobre dernier le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale a annoncé le 23
novembre que 85 élèves ont été
définitivement exclus de leur
établissement en cause des incidents
lors de la minute de silence observé en
hommage à Dominique Bernard et Samuel
Patti au total 605 sanctions ont été
prononcés lors de conseil de discipline
parmi les incidents relevés un élève
avait menacé de mettre une bombe de
s'était réjoui qu'un prof soit mort deux
autres avaient simulé des tirs d'armes
pour les actes de perturbation les plus
graves des mesures d'éloignement des
établissements des élèves à titre
conservatoire avait été décidé dès le 16
octobre date de
l'hommage